Douanier Rousseau facteur cheval ou
professeur Tournesol monsieur Gaston qui
vit dans un petit village de l'abri à
Neil la gilberg et tout cela et ses 80
printemps ne l'empêchent pas d'inventer
de découvrir sans cesse sa dernière
trouvaille est de taille et votre
récepteur de télévision sera bientôt bon
pour les oubliettes alors maintenant je
reçois de la Géorgie je reçois la télé
pour sauver la télévision la télévision
par laser il y a pas besoin de pause de
TSF de télévision alors maintenant les
lasers sans arrêt au-dessus de ma maison
et à l'intérieur ils sont là-dedans
alors je les vois les yeux fermés alors
vous voyez ça circule
de métal à la minute vers le nord mais
vous payez une redevance à la télévision
soviétique on paye rien pour ça c'est
gratuit c'est gratuit